NOW BACK TO THE "INGRAHAM
ANGLE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY NIGHT AND
TIME FOR FRIDAY'S FOLLIES.
MICHAEL MOORE BELIEVES ONLY ONE
PERSON CAN BRING TRUMP AND
BURGER KING WITH MEATLESS
PATTIES AND JOINING US WITH
RAYMOND ARROYO.
WE MISSED YOU LAST WEEK.
YOU HAD FUN IN FRANCE.
LIBERAL MICHAEL MOORE FEELS LIKE
HE HAS THE PERSON WHO CAN BEAT
TRUMP.
>> AMAZOLOGY HE FLOATED THIS
IDEA AFTER ONE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
DEBATES THIS WEEK.
>> THE ONLY -- WAY TO REMOVE
TRUMP IS TO CRUSH TRUMP.
THERE IS ONE PERSON THAT WOULD
CRUSH TRUMP.
SHE HASN'T ANNOUNCED YET.
HER LAST NAME RHYMES WITH OBAMA.
IN FACT IT IS OBAMA, MICHELLE
OBAMA.
>> THIS IS DESPERATION WRITTEN
LARGE.
RATHER THAN MAKING A CASE FOR
ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
RUNNING FOR THE OFFICE, MOORE
REACHES INTO NEVERLAND FOR
MICHELLE OBAMA.
MICHELLE OBAMA IS NOT
PARTICIPATING IN THE RACE.
SHE SAID THAT REPEATEDLY.
>> WOULD YOU EVER RUN FOR
ELECTED OFFICE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I HAVE NEVER WANTED TO BE A
POLITICIAN.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN ME TO
MAKE ME WANT TO RUN FOR ELECTED
OFFICE.
I WANT TO SERVE.
I WANT TO DO WORK.
I WANT TO BE OUT THERE.
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY WAYS TO
MAKE AN IMPACT.
POLITICS IS JUST NOT MY THING.
>> SHE AGAIN AND AGAIN SAID SHE
IS NOT DOING THIS.
WE COVERED THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHEN ROGERS
SAID WE ARE NOT JUST A POLITICAL
MOVEMENT.
WE ARE A BRAND.
THE OBAMA BRAND.
MICHELLE OBAMA MORE THAN ANYBODY
ELSE HAS CULTIVATED THAT BRAND.
NOW SELLING MORE THAN 10 MILLION
BOOKS WORLDWIDE.
SHE IS NOT ABOUT TO JEOPARDIZE
THAT TO RUN FOR POLITICAL OFFICE
WHERE SHE WOULD HAVE TO STAND
FOR POLICIES AND ISSUES THAT
WOULD DIVIDE AND DISSIPATE HER
FOLLOWERS.
>> Laura: THEY TRIED THIS WITH
PUSHING OPRAH AFTER HER AWARD
SPEECH AND GEORGE CLOONEY.
THEY PUSHED ONE LADY FOR 5
SECOND.
HONESTLY THEY PUSHED EVERY
CELEBRITY.
MICHELLE OBAMA IS A GLOBAL
CELEBRITY BRAND.
>> FROM QUEEN MICHELLE TO BURGER
KING.
THE FAST FOOT GIANT HAS A
MEATLESS WHOPPER.
IT'S CALLED THE IMPOSSIBLE
WHOPPER.
THE PATTIES ARE MADE BY
IMPOSSIBLE FOODS OF SOY PROTEIN.
COCONUT OIL AND IT ALLOWS IT TO
BLEED.
CUSTOMERS CAME THEY CAN'T TELL
THE DIFFERENCE.
>> THIS IS MADE OF [BLEEP] BEEF.
>> WE SWEAR IT'S NOT BEEF.
>> THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
IT TASTES JUST LIKE A WHOPPER
SHOULD TASTE.
>> IF YOU WANT A WHOPPER WHY
WOULD YOU GET A SOY ONE?
>> Laura: I GOT SICK WHEN YOU
SAID TO MAKE IT BLEED.
>> YOU SQUEEZE IT AND RED COMES
OUT.
>> Laura: I DON'T LIKE JEANETT
>> Laura: I DON'T LIKE GEANETT
>> Laura: I DON'T LIKE GENEETT
>> Laura: I DON'T LIKE GENETIT
>> Laura: I DON'T LIKE GENETI
GENETICALLY MODIFIED ANYTHING.
>> IT'S A DOLLAR MORE AND IT HAS
MORE SATURATED FAT AND SODIUM
THAN BEEF.
10 TIMES MORE!
THERE IS A REASON CHICK-FIL-A IS
AMERICA'S FAVORITE FAST FOOD
CHAIN.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THIS
RESCUE OF SEVERAL BEACHED WHALES
IN FLORIDA.
THE COASTGUARD AND LOCALS PULLED
THIS OFF.
IT WAS A POLITICAL RESCUE IN THE
MEDIA THAT WAS EVEN MORE DARING
THIS WEEK.
>> LOOKING AT BIDEN TONIGHT HE
HAD A STRONG PERFORMANCE
TONIGHT.
HE SHOWED SOMETHING HE DIDN'T
SHOW LAST TIME WHICH IS FIGHT.
>> HE HAD A STRONG NIGHT LAST
NIGHT.
JOE BIDEN CAME PREPARED TO
DEFEND HIS RECORD THIS TIME AND
GO ON OFFENSE.
>> HE GOT INTO THE FIGHT.
HIS TEAM WILL BE HAPPY HE FIRED
BACK.
>> Laura: THIS WAS THE JOE BIDEN
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT.
>> [STUTTERING].
WE SUPPORT OBAMACARE.
EXCUSE ME, THE FUTURE PRESIDENT
HERE THAT THE SENATOR IS TALKING
ABOUT IT.
HELP ME IN THIS FIGHT.
>> Laura: MAKE IT STOP!
>> POOR MAN.
I FELT BAD FOR HIM.
HE WAS TRYING TO GET THEM TO
TEXT 30.
HE SENT THEM TO A WEBSITE THAT
SUPPORTS PETE BUTTIGIEG.
>> Laura: I THINK HE HAD A GOOD
NIGHT.
>> HE DID?
>> Laura: LOOK, THEY WERE ALL
COMING AT HIM.
HE WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT DIDN'T
LOOK BAT BLANK CRAZY.
>> I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS
AND STAND BACK.
THE FACT SO MANY ON THE LEFT ARE
LOOKING FOR OTHER SOLUTIONS AND
NOT SPENDING ANY TIME OF MAKING
THE CASE OF BUILDING UP THE MEN
AND WOMEN ON THE STAGE.
THAT TELLS YOU SOMETHING.
IF JOE BIDEN IS THE FRONTRUNNER,
THIS IS A DANGEROUS PLACE.
>> Laura: I ALMOST SNEEZED ON
NATIONAL TV.